françois bayou est un enfant du pays
ce spécialiste de l'étude des animaux
dans leur milieu naturel a pendant trois
décennies sillonné le continu en afrique
ce baroudeur infatigable photographe
animalier passionnés de la faune a
retrouvé en 2005 le loiret désormais il
immortalise sur la pellicule une femme
un écosystème qui nous sont plus
familier
les deux expositions une pendant tout le
mois de juillet une parente mode photo
géante bien évidemment de deux mètres
sur un mètre qui sont exposés au fil du
chemin aidé d'un itinéraire que les gens
peuvent emprunter aussi bien les enfants
en bas âge que les personnes âgées et
les photos sont à découvrir une sorte de
jeu de piste si vous et au milieu d'un
paysage extraordinaire pour réussir ses
photos
la chance ne suffit pas c'est un travail
de longue haleine qui nécessite une
infinie patience
j'essaye de faire les photos un peu
extraordinaire dans le sens les
littéraires d'espèces ordinaire donc
pour ça il faut s'y prendre deux trois
façons 1 il faut faire de la prospection
sur le terrain pour voir que les oiseaux
qu'elle mammifères sont disponibles dans
un secteur donné
la seconde chose une fois que vous avez
localiser ces deux observer le
comportement des oiseaux et des
mammifères pour comprendre si vous en
avez pour 2 ou pour deux mois
la troisième des choses c'est de vous
approprier un terrain et d'y rester le
plus longtemps possible en visant
évidemment une distance la plus courte
possible
l'exposition de cartes animaux est une
initiative de l'office national des
forêts c'est à voir jusqu'au 30 août à
nogent sur vernisson